[Music]
on tv on radio and on your smartphone
this is talk tv
[Music]
i'm pissed morgan uncensored breaking
news tonight another horrific mass
shooting in america at least six people
are shot dead and 24 taken to hospital
after independence day celebration in
chicago turned into horror we'll have
all the latest including the fact the
shooter remains at large and will have
an eyewitness to the attack
woke and broke a british bank as
pronouns but loses customers we'll
debate the big pronoun showdown
as tennis reach breakpoint with aussie
wimbledon bad boy nick kyrios
and star mangles banner singing
superstar macy gray on why america
should ditch his famous flag
[Music]
[Music]
good evening i'm piers morgan uncensored
some breaking news tonight sad breaking
news another unspeakable mass shooting
in the united states at least six people
have been killed and two dozen others
hospitalized in an attack on a fourth of
july july parade in suburban chicago
police say the gunman is still at large
and still considered armed and dangerous
he's described as a young white man aged
approximately 18 to 20 which sadly
appears to fit the all too familiar
profile now of these mass shooters in
america there are no further details yet
on his moted but police believe he
opened fire from a stall rooftop
witnesses are described hearing a volley
of shots in quick succession and seeing
bloody bodies covered in blankets
well i'm joined now by eyewitness miles
zorensky
miles thank you so much for joining me
i'm so sorry you've had to go through
this it must have been an absolutely
horrific experience just if you could
tell me what you witnessed today
it was gut wrenching
and it was like out of a science fiction
movie but it was so real
um it was a nice day in in our suburb
highland park which my wife and i have
lived since 1976.
i took a walk to the parade as i usually
do for
30-odd years just to
take in the sights and i was about a
half a block to three quarters of a
block
uh away from the scene of the carnage
which was on central avenue which was
the main thoroughfare of our suburb at
and the cross street was second avenue
2nd street
and i at first i heard a pop
and then a second popped so i thought it
was the backfire of one of the vehicles
that started off the parade or maybe a
firecracker and then there were multiple
pops
pop pop pop
and i'd say there were two sets of pops
probably 13 15
20 each you know maybe 30
overall
and then all of a sudden the crowd
started rushing towards me or going west
on central avenue
and i and they were just it was like
mass hysteria
and so uh i was not knocked down but
then i kind of gingerly walked forward
and saw something i've never seen in my
entire life even having been in the
service a lot decades ago
of blood on the ground
individuals
with blood on them i saw at least a
couple
that had that were in a pool of blood
and not moving as if if they were
deceased
and even i saw i think i saw a young boy
who was ashen in his parents arms as he
was not moving either
it was just horrific
and what makes this
doubly
horrific i guess was that it was on july
4th the day that we celebrate our
country's founding
um
and it's it highland park is a lovely
law abiding community a suburb of
highland pa of uh chicago
um
we're not a troublemaker or rabble
rouser
and it can happen in highland park it
can happen in any area within the
country and yes of course it's happened
at churches and synagogues and schools
and entertainment venues
uh it was just horrific piers miles i
it's such a graphic description of what
you've been through and you've really
taken this to
to what happened
uh but you hit the nut on the head there
there have been so many mass shootings
in america horrific mass shootings but
for this to happen on july the 4th for
somebody to be on a rooftop of a store
deliberately targeting americans as they
celebrate their independence
it's it's a particularly heinous crime
what does it say to you
coming off the back of so many horror
mass shootings what does it tell you
about the state of your country right
now
well i didn't want to get into politics
but obviously uh um
we need to do more in the united states
elsewhere look what happened in
copenhagen the other day yeah um
to protect us from
gun violence
and those that think they have a free
reign
on guns which they don't the second
amendment in the
in our country is not um is not all
encompassing it's limited
uh given my my legal background i know a
little about a little bit about that but
um what does it say about the united
states indeed all over the world is that
people don't care about human life and
our politics in the united states
are an example of what is is going on
and
those that don't want to protect us from
guns just don't have the cajones excuse
my word
in passing appropriate legislation but
that's a political thing but having seen
it firsthand
god help us all
yeah miles i'm i'm so sorry again to you
and to everybody caught up in there my
son's just got back from being at
university of chicago so i know the city
well and i thought i used
i was an adjunct lecturer there at the
law school and they said it's a
wonderful school it's a wonderful city
it's been sadly ravaged by gun violence
but as you rightly say you know highland
is a very nice suburb of chicago it's
not a gang land area or anything like it
and for this to happen there uh on this
particular day is an appalling crime
miles thank you so much for joining me
thank you for having me pierce best
bye-bye wish you all the best
thank you well i wanted to celebrate
over a few minutes today the 4th of july
on behalf of my american friends
obviously it's a bittersweet day for we
brits because we got kicked out of the
country but america won its independence
and they come together on this day
usually every year to celebrate together
of all political persuasions
but it doesn't feel like that today does
it
this latest mass shooting another
horrific event
in a way horribly exemplifies so much of
the hatred and tribalism
in the us right now it's a country that
i love i love the people
i love the country
but where's the national unity where is
the united states
it looks to me more disunited than ever
well my first guest tonight was actually
someone i interviewed several days ago
before this horrific breaking news of
course
and she thinks that even the star
spangled banner itself should now be up
for debate as we try and bring the
country into a more unified place one
year ago grammy winning superstar macy
gray wrote nope calling for the redesign
of the most famous flag in the world to
better represent the diversity of the
country today while she was immediately
attacked by cavalcade of critics one
congresswoman suggested she didn't like
it she should leave the country but
mason gray insisted to me that she loves
america that her argument was simply
misunderstood
and tonight i started our interview uh
by asking her if she stands by that
argument and if so why
so basically
let me talk to you about a furore that
you're involved in last year because i
found it very interesting the way the
debate played out you wrote an op-ed for
market watch yes a year ago actually in
which you said that the american flag no
longer represents democracy and freedom
you wanted it changed
why
well i i just think that uh it's it's a
it's a it's like in a general thing it's
just a new day it's time that you know
you reboot the constitution the flag all
the all the old standards you know that
that our ancestors lived by you know
were right for for the time they lived
in but we're in a different time you
know so um
so the flag is uh so in the states you
know to me what the states do best
is diversity it's culture you know what
i mean without culture in america you
really don't have
much going on you know you have you know
i don't know amazon like what do you
have if you don't have color in the
states i mean i agree with that what i
would say to you is though that
it's such a divisive issue things like
the flag do you not think there's a
danger i'm interested in what how you
feel a year on from that debate you got
hammered obviously by a lot of people a
lot of americans were outraged others
thought you raised an interesting point
in a way it wasn't that dissimilar to
what colin kaepernick went through with
the protests that he was doing some
agreed with him others were furious do
you have any regrets about the what you
said about the flag
no in fact i'm excited to bring it up
again because i i think it's more
important now what what i want to do is
is more important now it's just
messaging it's just
it's just like if you if you
so my idea was to make the stars
the colors of all of us so that they saw
representing you one representing me one
representing everybody in the room right
so that way you look up to the flag and
you feel welcome you feel included you
feel like you belong there why does okay
let me play devil's advocate yeah which
is
i think the american flag is a fantastic
flag i love my flag here too
the english flag the uk flag that i love
these flags
to me they're not about
making any kind of diverse point they're
just great flags and if i was an
american most americans i've spoken to
about this they say
there are other ways to celebrate
diversity juneteenth is one right right
there are other ways to do this why go
after such a
powerful emblem of the united states of
america when it causes the whole debate
actually a lot of disunity whenever the
flag was was was conceptualized they
they made it based off what was going on
during that time which was a war that's
another thing we celebrate
a flag that represents war i actually
have an american flag on my office wall
at home yeah i think we've got a we've
got a picture of it
um i think here we go look that's my
office wall uh in london
uh i look at that every day uh it's
actually quite a unique one it's got 34
stars yes which means it was actually
the flag from the civil war period when
lincoln was president and that's the
only flag that was in use during
lincoln's presidency and i bought it at
an auction because america's been a
large part of my life and i i find it a
stirring
emblem but i never look at it and think
well that's about
white people or you know white power
over black people or that's attacking
diversity or it could be more diverse i
just think it's such a magnificent
emblem now i'm white so i might think
that
well it's not it's not that it's about
white people it's it's just that our
everything is different than when
lincoln was president so
and whoever designed that flag designed
it for that day
so i'm just saying what's wrong with the
new flag what's wrong with
representing where where we are now like
we no longer have 34 states right so
right so they made one with 50 states
well then they changed the flag over the
years that's true
when you got kicked back on this yeah
did it surprise you how ferocious some
of it was did you mind did you expect it
no i didn't expect it i i thought people
would agree with me
i thought people like yeah let's let's
do a new flag i don't know it's kind of
an art project it's just like well i
don't see why not that's my thing do you
feel that more people are aware of
racial injustice of racial equality do
you feel like the taking the knee which
went around the world
like wildfire especially after george
floyd was killed do you feel that that
all helps or are these just
token things which don't actually make
any tangible difference
um i i think it made a lot of people
aware i think when it comes to
changing someone's view on race or
people
uh that's that's more than a one event
that's not that's
you know that's growing up that's
parenting that's where you go to school
that's what neighborhood you live in
there's a lot that goes into how you
feel about people that aren't like you
you know what i mean do you feel that
america is more or less racist than when
you grew up it's definitely not as bad
you know uh i was born in the 60s so i
don't understand racism be honest with
you i like i get like i'm sitting here
with you
and we're different you know what i mean
and there might be things that i i would
be i wouldn't want to say in front of
you that i might say in front of my
friends of color and vice versa
but like to hate someone i want to kill
someone or
hold somebody down because of what they
look like i don't i don't understand i
mean i completely agree i think i think
most people would completely agree with
that i do think racism is a minority
fortunately in almost every country and
particularly america and britain i don't
think it's it by any means a popular
thing but it exists
and it's the it's what's the best way to
tackle it what's the best way to get rid
of it you have to let go of uh
needing to be better than than everyone
else you have to let go of
of of your hang-ups about slavery you
have to let go of your hang-ups about
superiority you have to you know it's
very personal how you feel about other
people you know like we could have a
conversation about how you feel about
women you know and then there would be
so many things that that went into that
you know i mean we're in an era now
basically you can't most public figures
are too terrified to even say what they
think a woman is i know i mean what if i
asked you what a woman is what would you
say
let's say uh a human being with uh boobs
how are you to start there yeah i mean
the dictionary is quite straightforward
it just looks like an adult female right
now a lot of people yeah see that now
that's a little getting confusing oh
they that's good that's good and i'm not
sure why really it's a bit like this
whole issue of transgenders in sport
it's not like i support all trans rights
to fairness and equality
but not where you have people born to
obvious physical superior bodies
transitioning and then thrashing the
women at the sport i totally agree and i
will say this and everybody's going to
hate me but as a woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
you feel that
i know that for a fact like if you want
me to call you or her i will because
that's what you want but that doesn't
make you a woman just because i call you
or her
and just because you got a surgery
because people do feel feel that
there's biological sex and then there's
gender identity that you can identify as
whatever you like in terms of agenda
right that's the freedom we live in but
actually you can't change the mechanics
of biological sex they are what they are
well just every like women go through
just a completely unique experience
and and surgery or
you know finding yourself doesn't
doesn't change that you know being a a
little girl is is a whole
epic book you know
and and you can't you can't have that
just because you want to be a woman i
mean you know when people like jk
rowling have said this
they get attacked they get abused
the canceled culture mob comes from me
she gets older she gets called
transphobic and so on you might get the
same for saying it but it's the truth
i'm not i i
and i don't think you should be called
transphobic just because you don't agree
with you know i i just there's a lot of
you know
judgment and throwing you know stones at
people for for just saying what it is
you know what i mean
you have hung out with some very
interesting people in your time yeah
prince was one of them you sat in a dark
room
he called me onto his room the lights
were out which was weird and you talked
for two hours in this dark room yeah and
he gave you a great bit of advice do you
remember it
yes he said uh just remember it's not
about you what do you mean by that that
as an artist is about what you give what
you how you make your fans feel i read
recently that you're you're looking for
love
well you know that's that's that's
subjective that's you know
that that could mean a lot of things
what did you mean by what did i mean i
don't know
i don't know you know i haven't been in
a relationship in a while and i just
kind of picture myself uh you know
doing all that right now because it's a
lot of work and i don't see it yet but
i'm thinking when i do i'm just gonna
have an audition really
yeah i'm just gonna like i have a cattle
call and i get to shoot
did i say that wrong i have a man called
a cattle tool yeah i'll pick the ones
you know a lot of balls turn up is that
the idea
and then i'll interview them
and then i'll
just to give them a bit of help before
they join the queue and it'll be a i'm
sure a very extensive line but
what advice would you give them about
the kind of man you're looking for
oh gosh
see that's that's a long okay let me
think
well you know just not to be corny but
there's energy you know there's
connection there's like you look at
someone and you you know
it's that thing
energy yes energy you know you're
comfortable with someone told small do
you care
yeah how tall are you six one oh plenty
of energy you're married
she'll probably she'll probably trade me
she's probably watching
but no but
but uh yeah definitely tall because i'm
tom 5 11. how many how many times have
you actually been properly in love in
your life do you think well i've been
married twice so that's two plus maybe
two more
four times it's difficult yeah to get to
go there you know well hard to be also
when you're as successful as you are
thank you and you're famous thank you
and you're doing all this and you're
being basically great it's hard to then
have a human relationship right where
you can i guess completely trust people
uh no i don't i don't have i'm not a big
i don't trust and i don't really worry
about that i just uh it's just a comfort
thing for me you know who i can sit with
and then be myself at least you know
most of the time when you came out with
your criticism of the american flag you
did also i think make it clear that you
were proud to be an american very i
loved by the country probably more than
most of the people who criticized me
right yeah i was going to ask you that
no i love my country i'm proud of my
country
i'm proud of where i'm from of you know
being a woman being black i love
everybody i can honestly say i love
everybody and if i could have the power
to let you relive one moment in your
entire
life yeah
outside of having your kids and getting
married what would you choose
boy
let's see
there's days in the week when i lay in
my bed in my underwear and i switch
channels and i don't have any and i'm
not worried about anything and they're
the best those are the best
and i just go through my channels and i
find something i don't have to get up
and go to peers morgan i'm saying i can
just lie here
[Laughter]
those are the best moments you know do
you sing when you're on your own you
just suddenly let rip
and i do you know i do i do start
singing yeah sometimes because i'm still
like i said working on my voice i'm
trying to get to a thing you know
i'm working on so i have a song called
uh every night but you got it here
that should actually be the the theme
it's out now yeah i know that yeah
from the new album the reset
congratulations
and then i have a song called thinking
of you okay
i'm drinking and i am thinking of you
and were you thinking of me when you
signed it totally
[Laughter]
absolutely macy it's great to see you uh
the new album the reset is on uh
released on july 8th the new single
every night is out now you just finished
your uk tour and you're on your on tour
in america now yes well best of luck
with it thank you lovely to see you
thanks for having me
on says the next is this the sex scandal
that may finally finish boris johnson
other that is from pest minster next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's growing anger among conservative
party rebels over prime minister boris
johnson's handing of yet another
parliamentary sex scandal deputy chief
whip chris pincher resigned from the
government on thursday after admitting
embarrassing himself while drunk he said
to have groped two men since then he's
faced a number of historical accusations
number ten was aware of some of these
claims before appointing him i'm joined
now by talk to you these people have
kate mccann okay every time i say this
is a scandal too far for boris johnson
we all kind of agree and then nothing
happens
he weasley carries on is he i mean is
this damning enough to maybe trigger
another vote of no confidence if they
change the rules to get rid of him
well that is the really big question
that conservative mps are asking is this
the final straw for boris johnson is
this the one effectively the nail in the
coffin and i think piers tonight it has
to be said that conservative mps are now
speaking out in ever-growing numbers and
they're doing it publicly caroline
knopes was speaking to us just before on
the news desk and she made some fairly
shocking allegations suggesting that
she'd encountered chris pincher in the
middle of the day on a tuesday drunk
she'd raised those allegations
literally just before he got caught
literally literally last week she'd
raised those allegations with senior
people in the party and they'd been
completely ignored now it's important to
say i've put those to chris pincher i've
not heard anything back yet but that
shows you doesn't it that this is not a
problem that people didn't know about
tonight we've
indicated that staff in number 10 young
male staff in number 10 were warned
against hanging out with chris pincher
because of allegations against him
suggestions as you say that the prime
minister did know about allegations and
just to remind everybody this is the
bloke in charge of of discipline of mps
he couldn't make it up he's a bloke
called pinscher running around getting
drunk and groping everybody and he's the
bloke in charge of people behaving
themselves
yeah and look you know boris johnson
spokesman today was asked did he say
that pincher by name pinscher by nature
and the spokesman didn't deny it this is
a problem that everyone was aware of so
to come back to your question piers is
it the end of boris johnson i think
there have been some serious questions
about his judgment not just for
appointing chris pincher but then
allowing him to continue in that post as
you say responsible for welfare at a
time when this is not the only scandal
that the conservative party has faced
i was going to say you know
i realized the game might be up for
boris this morning when i turned on to
see which poor cabinet minister was
going to be wheeled out to try and
defend the latest indefensible thing and
this guy appeared i mean i'll show his
picture for people i had literally no
idea who this bloke was let's have a
look
question and both last night and this
morning i spoke with number 10 to firmly
seek clarity as to the situation and who
knew what and i have had an assurance
from number 10 that the prime minister
was not apparently his name's will
quince and he's some junior minister but
the fact that not even grant
would go on tv to defend boris on this
one said to me that's it
yeah but look the point about will
quinn's you're right you know he was
very clear that he'd been told
specifically i've been told not i
believe the prime minister or i
understand boris johnson i've been told
and that's because ministers are now
really frustrated of going on tv having
to defend things and then everything
turning out to be untrue uh not very
much later but will quince was talking
about child care policy today on the tv
and essentially number 10 have been
saying this is going to save families a
lot of money wilquin said well it
probably won't you've got an even bigger
problem than these allegations when
you've got ministers going out on tv and
radio stations and saying the exact
opposite to number 10. that's a really
significant policy problem and that's
not going to go away it just seems like
every weekend new slew of scandals new
shame new embarrassment new pressure it
might with my old newspaper editor hat
on whenever you the phrase pressure was
mounting became the daily refrain for
months on end it normally ended in the
person under the mounting pressure
being either falling on their sword or
being pushed onto one
yeah what was that saying if you're on
the front page for 11 days straight or
in the newspapers for 11 days straight
then that's the end of your career
i got fired from the daily mirrors
editor on day 13.
so
i'm actually living proof i'm living
proof it can go on longer please you and
i have had this discussion before about
the end of boris johnson and when you
run through everything and you think
about all the logic here you think about
can a prime minister really survive the
things that he's had to survive again
and again and again the difference is
we're talking about boris johnson and
there is a mechanism for getting rid of
a leader in a party and he's just
survived that and unless the rules are
changed which i have to say i don't
think is necessarily going to happen
anytime soon he's safe from a vote like
that for at least another year all right
well here you go i'll bet you let's do
the old um what was that what was that
film with dan aykroyd and eddie murphy
trading places they did what was a one
pound bet wasn't it so why don't we have
a one dollar for them let's do a one
dollar bet i say boris gone by christmas
you want to take that bet
yeah i say he stays okay we're on one
dollar and i will will come and get it
okay mccann thank you very much
thank you
okay
well let me make a statement now i'm
piers morgan i am a man i identify as a
male i would hope that was reasonably
clear from my appearance but a great
number of businesses think we should be
displaying our pronouns in email
signatures or even name badges to avoid
the possibility of someone looking at me
for example and thinking i'm not sure
what he is if he doesn't have a little
name bag which i'm putting on myself
here now and i'll explain why in a
moment
let me just make sure i don't hit myself
with this pin um here we go there we go
so
halifax one of the biggest british banks
is asking staff to wear pronoun badges
they tweeted pronouns mata hashtag it's
a people thing
so far so virtue signaling and a welcome
step of course for inclusivity or was it
just bonkers well in just a moment i'll
be speaking to comedian james barr who
uses the pronouns he him his presumably
because he's a bloke and howard from
halifax who's wearing also pronouns he
him is but i don't think you really
think you want it do you have now howard
you might recognize because he was mr
halifax he used to be literally the guy
doing the ads for the bank take a look
maybe i'm a banker who's completely
obsessed
got a little
[Music]
okay well i'm with howard how great to
see you and comedian james barr is with
me as i mentioned james let me start
with you
here's the problem i have with what
halifax did if you want to do this
badge thing i've been to conferences
where people wear badges if you want to
do it fine the problem i have what
halifax did is whoever runs their
twitter account not only tweeted a load
of virtue signaling nonsense around it
but also started telling anyone who was
objecting well then you can take your
custom elsewhere which i thought was a
startling piece of absurd over-the-top
virtue signaling for the twitter account
of a british bank just stick to the
handling our money what's the matter
with you all
your view well let me first of all just
say the whole country was really hoping
that you would get that whole pin thing
wrong just now but i'm glad that you are
okay it took me a while actually
james
or do you feel happy now that you are
identifying correctly i think if we're
going to go in down the road of any
pronouns you like i would like you now
in this interview to keep calling me hot
hotter or hottest do you think that's
reasonable i disagree but i'm very happy
to call you by those because i respect
your pronouns as halifax do with their
class you don't actually think i am
possible so why would you
well i mean some might but i i don't but
that's how you want to identify so
that's how i now see you peers but
that's that's why i think the whole
thing is ridiculous and getting more
ridiculous and it's not about you can't
do it if you want to do it fine but when
i see a bank's twitter account
threatening customers and telling them
to leave if they don't like it i'm like
i think the customers were threatening
the bank and suggesting that they
thought it was awful and so they replied
with a clapback which is right saying
that if you disagree you can close your
account i think that's brilliant that's
exactly what we need from our allies and
people in this community
virtue signaling imbeciles why do you
who's clearly a a man i would presume
why do you need to have that
why do you need to have a badge saying
he him
because it shows people that i am
inclusive and i'm welcoming other people
it's not you're just a bloke well people
that don't identify as he him or she her
or anyone to be honest they just look
you say go work go broke i say if it
ain't woke fix it like we need to be
telling people that they are safe in our
company don't need to be telling me that
they are he him
they know that they're men
i mean this argument is so boring i'm so
bored of having this conversation
companies doing it then
no companies need to do it
let me bring in how it is howard look
but james is entitled his opinion and
this show is uncensored you absolutely
can have all sorts of opinions and
there'll be lots of people that agree
with him you used to be the front man
for the halifax back when you saw what
they did here what did you think well i
gotta be honest i was a little bit
saddened by it to be honest with you
because
when i first heard of this message
coming out where they were saying that
um you know they were changing certain
parts of the organization and then if
you weren't happy with it you know you
could close your account i felt quite
sad about that because halifax has
always put its customers first and
rightly so
and anything that detracts from that i
think is just wrong um you know we
prided ourselves in customer service
we positioned ourselves as as the um you
know the country's um
people's bank
uh and rightly so because we had great
accounts and we you know we considered
ourselves as a family and we wanted to
bring our customers in as a family so i
thought this uh thing was really bizarre
and i think it's just totally
unnecessary and we're seeing so many
companies now
getting into this virtue signaling about
these kind of issues and sort of
bullying people into going along with it
you know sort of freedom of speech and
you're on your right not to do this kind
of thing you're immediately condemned as
some kind of bigot if you don't wear
your pronoun badge or you don't do this
or you don't do that i really resent
that well i
i don't think that's right i think
because when you start individualizing
people that's when you have a problem i
just think that people need to take a
common sense look at this
um obviously uh from halifax point if
they want to make changes that's fine
but i think that they've sort of you
know they sort of just missed the boat a
little bit on this one because their
focus should be on their customers we
all know that the customers of of you of
your organization are your lifeblood um
so
you know to me i just find it really
really bizarre that they're being forced
i think that i i read something where
they said that there was a a choice i
would have to say that if i was still
working for halifax i wouldn't have a
badger pronouns i would have my name on
it but i don't think i would choose um
to have you know to specify a parameter
that would just be simply my choice
right um
because you know and the funny thing
about it is a lot of people really don't
really take notice of name badge
something when you go to the branches
our customers just want to make sure
that we're looking after their bank
that's all i care about that's let me
bring james back in at the end i mean
there's anything that howard just said
he was the face of halifax there's
anything he said made you pause for
thought
uh no because to be honest and without
being rude um howard hasn't been the
face of halifax for over 10 years and is
quite frankly irrelevant in this
conversation as well as that i mean gay
marriage wasn't even legal when uh
howard was working
no i don't think it really matters at
all what does gay marriage have to do
with it
i'm just saying that the world is a very
different place and this is all about
the customers but what is gay marriage
sorry i mean i supported gay marriage
well what the hell's that got to do with
wearing badges you're saying he and him
when you're blind a very different place
to this conversation yeah but it's not
james you see your world is and it's a
very small world actually and the vast
majority of people in this country do
not agree with you it might be a
startling shock to your system but not
everybody would like to ask you this why
is this so offensive to you how is this
affecting you i find it offensive when a
british bank starts telling people on
twitter you can just
sod off if you don't want to wear the
pronoun badges banks will follow suit
and actually people have to start
putting their money under their
mattresses again because actually people
will pick what people will do they'll
switch to other banks because when
companies go like this they normally go
broke very quickly you know that i know
that so you think you speak for the
majority actually you don't but you
don't speak for the majority i would say
you speak for less than percent of the
country that you talk well i woke up
doing an amazing amazing thing by
thinking about that one percent of the
country that don't feel safe to walk out
of their front door and they're telling
that no one's gonna feel safer wearing a
badge saying him
he trust me nobody nobody in the world
if i would feel less so as i said
earlier when i walk around with my back
saying hot hotter hottest i'm going to
feel seriously under threat of all these
things
for trans people and non-binary people
that aren't in the conversation isn't
this just wonderful actually i don't
think there's any conversation that
takes place at all these days without
trans people being mentioned so they're
in every conversation you know what
that's a very good point and they just
want a boring life pierce they actually
most trans people i know do and they
actually are have far more common sense
and they think this kind of thing is
ridiculous most trans people i know it's
not every single trans person it's the
activist who are destroying lies for
trans people by making these stupid
virtue signaling things all the time all
trans people
they don't need a bad it's not even what
they're the bank that's causing that
trauma it's interviews and conversations
and debates just like this trans
people's lives are not up for debate as
i said they want a boring life like you
and me and possibly unemployed my life
isn't remotely boring james and actually
yours isn't you're a funny guy you're a
good comedian so i'll give you that but
it's a good debate thanks for coming on
i appreciate it we're on censor we like
all of you howard great to see you thank
you and you were the face of halifax and
for me you always will be thank you so
much good to see you
well i'm sensing next through to the
quarterfinals of wimbledon those tennis
had enough of the nasty aussie nick the
beast
curios tonight's pierce back richard
zeiss avatina will debate that a few
minutes time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
i just want to wish my great friend
sharon and aussie osborne a very happy
40th wedding anniversary today and they
said it wouldn't last look at them a
wonderful picture that sharon tweeted a
great couple
my god they've had one hell of a
marriage good bad ugly fantastic one of
my favorite couples in the world so
happy anniversary now
one of my least favorite people nick
curios has booked his spot in the
quarterfinals of wimbledon after making
a lazarus light recovery from the
crippling shoulder injury which he was
using to blame every point he lost
earlier in the game but after the drama
of his clash with stephanos i can't even
pronounce it
we saw kyrie i'll start with another
fine the 27 year old largely kept his
behavior in check on sunday court but
does the sport had enough of nasty nick
well the pierce back joins me now talk
tv presenter and leader of reform uk
richard tyson legal journalist ava
santina welcome to both of you so let's
take a little look at the highlights of
kyrie it was pretty quiet today but on
saturday he gave us the full range of
curios the brat
it's constant bullying
[Applause]
i'm not sure how i bullied him life i
was he was the one hitting balls of me
i don't like bullies so you can hit a
ball if you can't hit someone and not
get something
i don't like people that put other
people down are you dumb apart from me
just going back and forth the umpire
fair bit let's get a new empire i did
nothing towards stefanos today that was
disrespected
yeah you know what bro you're my douche
of the day every day funnily enough no
one even comes close to him um
this is what pat cash had to say former
wimbledon great obviously what he said
about curios
it was absolutely mayhem it's
he's brought tennis to the lowest level
i can i can see as far as gainsmanship
cheating
manipulation abuse
aggressive behavior to lines to umpires
to linesman he was lucky to even get
through the first set he should have
been defaulted in the first in the first
it's about the first set
and it's got something he's got to be
done about
that it's his absolute circus well i
completely agree ava i'm glad to hear
you speaking like this i think it's
disgraceful
it's not even about tennis i think just
as a man i'd be humiliated if i saw
anyone i knew in my life acting like
that it's utterly disgraceful and you
know what the thing that really bothers
me about it is that serena williams in
2018 at the us open she was called
hysterical because she got upset when
she lost her match you know she broke up
tennis racket fine she was angry but why
aren't we calling him hysterical why
aren't we calling him the baby that he
is i think that's a really good point
richard serena williams did get buried
when she behaved that way any woman
actually that behaves i remember arthur
ashe uh who was one of the first great
black tennis stars in america i remember
him saying that if he'd behave like john
mcenroe he would have been drummed out
of tennis which i thought was also at
the time a perfectly reasonable point to
make completely i mean it's a fantastic
boy you may have it but the reality is
what's he trying to achieve i mean is he
trying to outdo mcenroe does it help him
uh you know sort of get to greater
height i think he does i think he fires
him up yeah i think he's at all in his
armory yeah but actually he's not been
that successful you know recently so
it's sort of maybe he's trying a new
tactic look it's not tennis it's not
wimbledon but in a sense there's a chunk
of the crowd that loves the villain yes
he loves the rose oh he had a pattern
that's part of it djokovic didn't have
anything like the turnout that he did so
that so there you are that sort of
proves it in a way
um his customers the crowd they love the
villain
and they love them
in the sense i remember mcenroe and it
was exciting to watch but he was utterly
obnoxious that's episode mcenroe he's
become this very charming commentator we
all love him and we've kind of forgotten
with the mists of time he was what he
was actually like he was terrible too he
was awful he was appalling maybe there's
hope in 20 or 30 years curios will
actually be mellowed and be a a
sort of an ambassador
i think he's just he's just got this
valve in him and he i mean i'm going on
friday i'm just hoping that on friday he
gets knocked out in front of me and the
last side he has is of me waving goodbye
that would be my dream well i don't know
he's also got he's admitted to having a
drinking problem before hasn't he
actually today he gave an interesting
interview post match in which he said
that when he played on centre court
before they think against djokovic
someone like that he said that he
literally his coach came and got him
from a pub in wimbledon i think probably
the dog and fox is his usual lair
and i was on the wimbledon news so i
know all the pubs there like the back of
my hand that he he got dragged out at 00
am to play on centre court the next day
and that was a second round match on
center court
so he's he's been a you know he's he's
been a player he's been a player he's i
think he's he's playing the gallery yeah
he's enjoying his sort of moment in the
sun does he let's be honest with each
other all of us does he make it more
more exciting and interesting to watch
even if we can't stand his behavior
i think it probably does and i think
that's why he fills the crowd you know
ultimately the customers have spoken
they've filled the center court i know
unlike something they were cheering him
and i made a point of watching him today
just to see if he was going to kick off
and i hate myself or he's like eating a
mcdonald's and the self-loathing that
comes after you've fallen for what you
said in the moment it tastes really good
you know um let's talk about mick jagger
so i had this debate the other day you
know what we're gonna talk about it
after the break because they're all
shouting in my ear and when they do that
i know it's time to have a little break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well the piece back is still with me
talk to you presenting leader of reform
cambridge and time people journalists
8017. so last week i am used the idea
that mick jagger is not a great singer
never has been that's one of the reasons
why his voice today sounds pretty well
as rough as it's always sounding because
he's never been a great singer unlike
diana rossi was a great singer and now
sadly isn't so good or paul mccartney or
whatever uh mick jagger has now entered
the debate here's what he said about his
own voice have you got a good voice no
technically no not really
i mean i'm lucky i still can sing
more or less like
the same notes when i was 19.
but not great voice but it's okay it
does its job
exactly
exactly thank you samick exactly the
point i was making you are the greatest
rock star there's ever been you're the
greatest rock star you need to have a
great voice leave back to other singers
just be mick who did a brilliant show at
hyde park at the weekend fantastic still
doing it but the beauty is he sounds the
same pretty much as he's always done
because he never sounded that good
great man uh now the other one i want to
talk about on music and i'll come to the
pack on this is adele who is still
whining about the show she canceled in
vegas when a lot of people lost a lot of
money who planned trips and everything
and she just canceled the last minute
here's what she said about the
cancellations
i'm not going to just do a show because
i have to or because people can be let
down or because you know we're going to
lose loads of money
really
really adele you're not going to do a
show because people are going to be let
down now i'm sorry but i come from an
old school that musicians when they do
big shows and put them on and people buy
tickets they turn up the show goes on
you don't just flounce off to your
hollywood mansion and then months later
say i'm not going to do it because
people are let down yeah but then you
get amy winehouse at best of all who was
half dead on stage and should have
absolutely not been there that's
different she had an addiction how is
that still has no addiction to her own
fame but she's preventing herself from
getting into a place where she does have
an addiction she's saving herself no
she's done do me a favor
from a breakdown
and it wasn't a question of a few days
we're now five months later and there's
still no shows booked she doesn't care
about her customers what's going on you
know ultimately i mean the customer is
always right and she i think she's using
and abusing her customers
she's a brilliant singer she's become a
real spoiled little diva i think
amazing by the way talk about voices one
of the greatest voices in the world
fantastic singer i just find her antics
now really irritating by the way she
talks irritating i find what she says
about her fans irritating no sense of
accountability no sense of returning all
the money they all wasted on flights and
hotels everything none of it i have no
compulsion she says in basically
honoring people who are going to be let
down
sorry you're not having yourself not
have mick jagger would never do that no
he wouldn't i mean never look i'm an
adele fan but you don't treat people
like that you don't treat your fans like
that i think it's just talking of of how
we treat people these are the protesters
who at the weekend they were invading
the formula one track
yes uh today a group of them uh these
are the eco warriors they actually glued
themselves to a constable painting then
we got a picture of it have we
got the constable painting
uh because i just wonder i don't wish
harm on anybody i just wondered though
if they aren't going to glue themselves
to these kind of things why don't we
just leave them there richard
quickly
it's appalling what they're doing you
know they're they're obstructing uh
they're disrupting it's completely
different
let's just leave them glued to it right
no fantastic i think really brilliant
wonderful leaping on the formula one
tracks
you think that's fantastic it's crazy
it's irresponsible and you know we
shouldn't we shouldn't let it happen
voice of common sense voice and woke
insanity that's it from me what are you
up to keep it uncertain thank you to my
facts
[Music]
join me ian collins every day on talk tv
there is nothing we hate more than
hypocrisy discussing the big issues why
was it so hard to establish the deputy
leader was at a meeting with her
colleagues the callers alan in grimsby
tracy in burton on trent dave thank you
very much picking apart
the big stuff this simply does not wash
look who's back under the spotlight
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm nadira tudor at least
six people have been killed and dozens
more are seriously injured after a
gunman opened fire on a fourth of july
parade in a chicago suburb the suspect
who's still at large shot at the crowd
in highland park at least one person has
died and three others were taken to
hospital following a gas explosion at a
block of flats in bedford witnesses say
they saw one person leaping from a
second floor window to escape the blaze
and zakir starmer has ruled out to
rejoining the eu or the single market if
labour comes to power insisting such
moves would so further division in
britain he also said the uk would not
join a customs union under his party's
leadership as he set out a five-point
plan to make brexit work that's all for
now we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you